-Bonjour.
A l'heure de l'urgence climatique,
comment continuer à se déplacer
en réduisant notre empreinte carbone
et la pollution qui tue
40 000 personnes en France par an ?
Comment se passer de la bagnole,
moyen de transport
préféré des Français,
y compris
pour de courtes distances
et jusqu'au plus haut
sommet de l'Etat ?
-On est attachés à la bagnole,
on aime la bagnole.
Et moi, je l'adore.
-Cette bagnole, qui incarne donc
le progrès, la liberté
et à qui on voue un culte
quasi mystique,
ce doudou d'acier, disons-le,
n'est pas franchement neutre,
Raphaël Hitier.
-Le transport
représente un tiers des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre, en France,
dont la moitié
par les véhicules particuliers.
On en compte
presque 39 millions,
un chiffre en constante augmentation
depuis des décennies.
Aujourd'hui, 98 % du parc automobile
roule au diesel ou à l'essence,
et seulement 1,5 %
à l'électricité exclusivement.
-Alors, revoir nos mobilités
est donc une nécessité,
mais suffit-il de le dire
pour le faire, est-ce à la portée
de ceux qui ont besoin
de la voiture pour travailler ?
Sommes-nous tous garés
sous la même enseigne
que l'on vive en ville
ou à la campagne ?
Quelles sont les alternatives
et sont-elles toutes
à portée de portefeuille ?
En attendant,
les ventes de SUV explosent,
au point
qu'on peut se demander
si on ne roule pas
à contresens de l'histoire.
Au fait, maman,
j'ai arrêté l'avion.
Générique
...
Avec nous, la députée européenne
d'Europe Ecologie Les Verts,
Karima Delli.
Bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Marie Chéron,
de l'association Transports
et Environnement.
-Bonjour.
-Et François Roudier,
porte-parole
de la Plateforme automobile
de France,
bonjour.
-Bonjour.
-Bienvenue à vous trois.
Avant de vous laisser la parole,
passons par le salon de l'auto
qui s'est tenu fin septembre à Lyon.
C'est l'occasion
pour les constructeurs
d'exposer leurs nouveaux modèles
et pour les particuliers
de les essayer voire plus.
L'édition 2023 a mis la gomme
sur l'électrique et l'hybride,
et toujours à l'honneur,
les SUV,
devenus les véhicules
les plus vendus en Europe.
Seulement, ces 4x4 urbains
sont plus lourds,
donc plus énergivores,
donc plus polluants,
champions des ventes
et des émissions de CO2.
Pour résumer, un paradoxe
à l'ère de la sobriété.
Le Tout oppose,
un reportage d'Alexis Breton,
Jawar Nadi et Joseph Alai.
Musique pesante
-En banlieue lyonnaise,
c'est jour de fête
pour la bagnole.
Le salon de l'automobile
a lieu tous les deux ans.
76 000 visiteurs
et plus de 50 marques qui viennent
présenter leurs modèles.
Parmi elles, Honda.
*-Allez, on y va.
Je me présente, Pierre Guignot,
directeur France de la marque.
On est très heureux
d'être présents.
-La marque japonaise, premier
constructeur de moteurs au monde,
fête ses 75 ans d'existence.
Applaudissements
-Maintenant,
on va allumer ce gâteau.
-Pour cette édition lyonnaise,
la marque présente en exclusivité
3 nouveaux modèles au public.
Monsieur le directeur général
nous fait visiter son stand.
-Bienvenue chez Honda.
A côté de moi, vous découvrez
le tout nouveau CR-V,
on vient de le lancer.
C'est un vaisseau amiral pour nous,
c'est le SUV iconique.
Ca a été un des SUV
les plus vendus au monde.
-CR-V, 1,9 tonne.
-Mais c'est pas la seule.
On a lancé 3 nouveaux modèles.
Vous avez devant vous le ZR-V.
On est sur une voiture
qui fait 4,56 mètres,
donc plus compacte.
-ZR-V, 1,6 tonne.
-Après, on a le HR-V.
Le HR-V, en SUV...
SUV, il vient...
CR-V, ZR-V, HR-V.
Vous avez les 3 tailles
devant vous.
Un véhicule encore plus compact.
-HR-V, 1,4 tonne.
De quoi énerver surtout
les opposants au SUV.
SUV
ou véhicule utilitaire sportif
pour les novices.
Des véhicules plus lourds
et plus polluants.
Au salon de l'automobile de Lyon,
ils sont partout.
Depuis quelques années,
ce sont les plus vendus
dans le monde.
Une mode des grosses voitures
aujourd'hui dénoncée
comme la pire idée au pire moment
par certains.
Klaxon
La France compte près de 39 millions
de voitures en circulation.
Ce chiffre ne cesse d'augmenter.
Dans cet embouteillage de moteurs
et pots d'échappement,
un véhicule est en passe
de remplacer tous les autres :
les SUV, donc.
En France, leur vente
a été multipliée par 7
en une seule décennie.
Une mode des faux 4x4
encouragée par la publicité
qui vend un véhicule sûr, familial
et avide de grands espaces.
Plus hauts, plus larges
et plus chers,
ils sont, en moyenne, 200 kg
plus lourds qu'une voiture.
Ils utilisent
plus de matières premières,
consomment plus
et rejettent, en moyenne,
15 % de CO2 supplémentaires.
Voiture du futur pour les uns,
catastrophe environnementale
pour les autres. Deux visions.
D'un côté, Yves Carra,
porte-parole de l'association
Mobilité Club France,
et de l'autre, Loup Espargilière,
journaliste,
à Vert, le média.
-Oui, la voiture
fait toujours rêver,
oui, elle est utile,
malgré ce que pourraient dire
certains politiques,
on aime la voiture,
car c'est la liberté.
-Il faudrait qu'on accélère
extrêmement vite
sur la réduction
des gaz à effet de serre,
et là, débarque
l'arme fatale, le SUV,
qui émet bien plus
que les autres voitures,
et qui contrecarre les efforts
faits par ailleurs.
-Au salon de l'automobile,
des milliers de visiteurs
attendent l'ouverture.
Ils ont hâte d'admirer les nouveaux
modèles et de les essayer,
comme Dragan, qui est, lui,
venu pour acheter une voiture.
-Côté conducteur ?
-OK.
*Bip
-On sait comment elle s'ouvre.
-Avec un moniteur
de la marque Honda,
il va prendre le volant
de ce SUV.
-On y va ?
-Long de 4,7 mètres
et pesant un peu moins de 2 tonnes,
ce SUV hybride est le plus gros
de la gamme Honda.
Un gabarit qui peut poser
des problèmes de conduite.
-Faut juste faire attention
au dos d'âne,
assez costaud.
-Oui.
Carré.
Ah oui.
-On teste les suspensions !
-Euh... Là, c'est pas top.
-On peut le changer.
-Oui.
-J'adore. Vraiment.
C'est absolument
ce que je recherchais,
au niveau du gabarit.
Quand on y a goûté,
d'avoir les véhicules surélevés,
on a du mal à revenir
aux véhicules conventionnels.
Je suis bien partant
pour celui-là.
-Parfois, il y a des critiques
adressées aux SUV.
Qu'en pensez-vous ?
Il rit.
-Question piège !
On m'avait pas prévenu,
pour cette question !
Euh...
Sur les véhicules,
ils ont raison.
Sur tous les véhicules.
J'éteins ?
-On peut.
-Les écologistes ont raison,
mais il va acheter ce monstre
de tôle et d'acier.
En France,
46 % des nouvelles immatriculations
sont des SUV,
devenus
en quelques années
les plus populaires.
-Les voitures ont pris du poids,
les voitures ont pris de la taille,
on a mis un mot, dessus,
"SUV",
mais c'est une erreur marketing.
"Voiture familiale",
ça passerait mieux.
Appelez-le "monospace",
plus de problème.
-En comptant la fabrication
et le roulage des SUV,
dans le monde,
tout ça émet quasiment
1 milliard de tonnes de CO2.
Pour un ordre d'idées,
c'est ce qu'émet le Japon,
en 1 an,
ou la France et l'Allemagne.
En gros, si les SUV étaient un pays,
appelons-le le "SUV-land",
ce serait le 6e émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre sur Terre.
-Des chiffres à faire frémir
tout habitant
un peu sensé de la planète,
et les écologistes
aussi, évidemment.
A l'entrée du salon,
C. Drognat,
porte-parole d'Alternatiba,
tente d'alerter le public.
-Bonjour. Vous voulez
une petite fiche d'infos
sur les SUV ?
-Non, merci.
-Pas de souci.
Bonne journée.
On a préparé une fiche
d'information sur les SUV.
Ca vous intéresse ?
On communique
sur ce qu'est un SUV,
pour un peu contrebalancer
le message publicitaire
des constructeurs.
-OK. Merci.
-Ca vous parle, monsieur ?
-Les SUV, oui, ça me parle.
-Vous en avez un ?
-Oui, oui.
-On n'est pas écolos,
ça nous intéresse pas !
-Ecoutez,
y a pas de souci.
-Pas facile de convaincre
ces passionnés d'automobile.
-C'est vraiment
pour contrebalancer
cette omniprésence médiatique
de la publicité
pour les véhicules lourds.
L'année dernière,
les constructeurs ont dépensé
à peu près 2 milliards d'euros
dans des publicités pour les SUV.
C'est quelque chose
qu'il faut arrêter.
-Dernière tentative,
avec ces étudiants
en école d'ingénieur.
Ce sera encore pire.
-On a des informations
sur les véhicules lourds,
la mode des véhicules lourds.
Intéressés ?
-Tant qu'il y a un V10,
ça nous va.
On en a rien à faire,
de la consommation.
-Pour de vrai ?
-Ouais.
-Et les questions écologiques ?
-Je m'en fous.
-Je suis pas très écologiste,
j'aime bien quand ça fait du bruit.
C'est bien de trouver
des alternatives
qui gardent
ce qui fait du bruit
et qui permettent
de moins polluer.
-Les SUV, c'est une aberration,
mais les gens cherchent
de la sécurité, aujourd'hui.
Il faut les comprendre.
Ca, ça fait plaisir.
La petite Mustang,
ça fait plaisir.
Je vais y aller.
Bonne journée.
-Avec de tels ingénieurs,
la planète est mal barrée.
-Aujourd'hui,
une voiture sur deux vendues,
c'est un SUV.
C'est une voiture normale.
Depuis 20 ans, l'automobile
a fait des efforts considérables
en matière de pollution :
des filtres à particules,
moins de consommation.
-Pour des trajets d'1 km,
réalisables en 12 minutes à pied,
les gens prennent la voiture
à 50 %.
On dans une culture
où la voiture est plébiscitée
pour tous les trajets,
même les trajets courts,
parce que c'est
le mode de transport
le plus commode, aujourd'hui.
-Une culture de la voiture
qui devient une culture du SUV,
et pas qu'en France.
En Europe, plus d'une voiture
vendue sur deux
est un SUV.
Au lieu de freiner
la tendance,
l'industrie a une solution
pour en vendre encore plus :
le SUV électrique.
Anne-Marie Baezner est
la directrice du salon de Lyon
depuis 2015.
-Moi, je l'aime bien, la 208.
-Son rôle :
faire venir les marques
et s'assurer que ses clients
sont contents.
-Ca va ? Tu vas bien ?
Les commandes, ça se passe bien ?
Le rythme ?
-Le rythme, on est
dans un avancement qui nous va.
-Renaud Mouly représente
le groupe Stellantis,
qui détient les marques
Peugeot ou Citroën.
Il propose
des SUV électriques.
-Il y a un mouvement
fort sur l'électrification,
il est clair et vous le voyez ici.
On a des concurrents
qui ne présentent
que des électriques.
-En 2019, en France,
la part de véhicules
électriques et hybrides
rechargeables, c'était de 2 %.
Et fin août 2023,
c'est de 24 %.
-Il se vend 8 voitures sur 10
en hybride. On peut rouler
30 à 40 % de son trajet
en électrique,
ce qui est pas mal,
et ensuite,
en thermique.
C'est écologique, économique,
moins à l'achat,
mais c'est très pratique.
-Un SUV électrique est plus lourd
qu'un thermique.
Il va émettre moins de gaz
à effet de serre
qu'un véhicule thermique.
Mais la pollution en ville
est due aux particules fines
issues du roulage et du freinage.
Un véhicule lourd va émettre
plus de particules,
et on ne règle pas
ce sujet de pollution.
-Sans compter la pollution engendrée
par la fabrication des batteries.
Mais alors, pourquoi achète-t-on
autant de SUV ?
Peut-être parce que nous sommes
constamment incités à le faire.
C'est l'avis d'Ellyn et Tom,
deux militants
d'Extinction Rebellion.
-C'est mensonger,
ce salon de l'automobile.
Où sont les voitures ?
Je ne vois que des minibus.
Aucun constructeur
ne fait pas de SUV.
La taille de la Jeep.
-Les jeunes écologistes
sont des habitués
des actions coup-de-poing,
mais pas cette fois.
L'année dernière,
11 militants s'étaient collés
les mains à des Ferrari
au Mondial de l'auto, à Paris.
Une action pour laquelle
ils devaient être jugés
en octobre dernier.
Ellyn et Tom ne veulent pas
leur porter préjudice
avant le procès.
-On peut ouvrir le coffre ?
-Oh mon pote !
-C'est ça qui est énorme.
-C'est mon appart !
-Là, il y a un petit salon, ici.
Des amis vivent dans des voitures
plus petites que ça.
-Ils gardent le sourire
mais ils n'oublient pas
l'essentiel :
leur combat
contre les SUV et leur cheval
de Troie : la publicité.
-C'est la pub qui joue énormément
dans le truc de vendre
une image de quelque chose
de très désirable.
Il y a quand même
un imaginaire de :
"Je suis toute seule sur ma route."
On voit jamais un SUV
dans des bouchons ou en ville,
c'est dans des grandes autoroutes
en lacet.
-Effectivement,
dans leurs pubs,
voici ce que nous montrent
les grandes marques :
de magnifiques routes
sans circulation,
dans des décors de rêve
qui nous parlent d'aventure
et avec des slogans
qui se veulent percutants.
-Nous, les humains, ne sommes pas
les animaux les mieux équipés.
Pas de fourrure,
pas de griffes...
-Mais des SUV.
Musique grandiose
-Alors que la réalité,
c'est ça.
Ca change tout, n'est-ce pas ?
-Les SUV en ville sont coincés
dans les bouchons,
ça klaxonne, ça dépasse.
Il faut combattre le green washing
dans la publicité.
Beaucoup de SUV sont vendus
comme écolos parce qu'hybrides
alors qu'ils ont
un impact climatique déplorable.
Et il faut investir l'imaginaire
dans le cinéma.
Je rêve d'une poursuite
dans un James Bond
où il serait avec un vélo
et pas une grosse bagnole,
tout le monde trouverait ça
classe.
Il faut ringardiser les SUV,
parce que les SUV,
c'est un grave problème
pour le climat.
-En France, certaines municipalités
ont décidé
de ne pas attendre
les blockbusters écolos pour agir.
C'est le cas de Lyon.
Le mairie,
dirigée par les écologistes,
souhaite réduire la place
de ces véhicules dans ses rues
en s'attaquant au stationnement.
Valentin Lungenstrass
est adjoint
en charge des transports.
Il explique son projet.
-Avec une tarification
progressive du stationnement,
avec 3 catégories
où, en fonction du poids
et de la motorisation,
on sera dans une catégorie.
-Concrètement, plus la voiture
est lourde et polluante,
plus le tarif est élevé,
de 15 euros par mois
jusqu'à 45 euros pour les gros SUV.
-Les grands véhicules
ont un impact sur la pollution,
sur le changement climatique,
sur la sécurité routière,
sur les métaux utilisés,
qui sont un impact trop important.
Des personnes ont besoin
de se déplacer en voiture,
pas de souci,
mais il vaut mieux de déplacer
avec un véhicule de 1000 kilos
et qui prend un espace réduit
dans l'espace public.
-C'est tout sauf la liberté,
la bagnole. En France,
en moyenne, chaque mois,
un véhicule coûte
entre 400 et 500 euros par mois.
C'est extrêmement cher.
Permettre aux gens de se libérer
de la voiture individuelle,
c'est redonner du pouvoir d'achat.
Ce discours
doit devenir entendable
et il l'est pas aujourd'hui.
-La voiture fera toujours partie
de notre quotidien.
Quelle voiture, quelle énergie,
quelle taille, je ne sais pas,
mais elle fera toujours partie
de notre quotidien,
pour le pire ou le meilleur.
-Le pire ou le meilleur.
On a compris
la mode du SUV.
Est-ce qu'elle est compatible
avec les objectifs climatiques
à l'horizon 2035 ?
-Si cette voiture devient
ce qu'on en fait,
c'est-à-dire si elle est
électrique,
oui, parce que c'est une voiture,
selon ce qui a été décidé
en Europe,
qui va émettre 0 CO2
à l'échappement.
Donc c'est pas tout
ce qu'il faut faire,
il y a d'autres choses
qu'on a lancées
dans l'industrie.
C'est le coût global en CO2,
de toute la fabrication des pièces
de la voiture.
Vous savez qu'on est sur une vision
un peu différente
des véhicules importés de Chine.
Un véhicule importé de Chine
pose
un gros problème en CO2.
Pour vous répondre,
on peut pas répondre tout de suite.
-Avant de parler d'électrique,
comment expliquez-vous
que plus les normes se durcissent,
plus les SUV sont plébiscités ?
Sachant que ces mastodontes
rejettent,
selon les modèles,
entre 11 et 26 %
de dioxyde de carbone,
et qu'ils sont la deuxième source
de croissance des émissions
de CO2 en France,
juste derrière l'aérien.
-Attention à l'appellation
SUV, parce que SUV,
c'est l'appellation commerciale.
Vous avez des petites voitures
qui ressemblaient à des SUV
et qu'on appelait pas SUV.
Une 205 ou une R5
de notre jeunesse,
ça avait le look d'un SUV.
-Non, non, pas du tout.
-C'était carré...
-C'était tout petit.
-On appelait ça même
des 4x4, les minis 4x4.
Aujourd'hui, il faut appeler
un chat un chat.
Un SUV est un SUV.
-Non, vous pouvez pas
dire ça.
-Le problème, c'est le poids.
-L'un des critères,
vous le savez aussi bien que moi,
c'est la question du poids.
A partir de poids,
on commence à dessiner quoi ?
Le type de véhicule.
-Depuis 10 ans,
nos voitures
prennent 1 centimètre
tous les 2 ans,
et 10 kilos par an.
Pardon.
Est-ce que l'offre des constructeurs
est alignée
aux objectifs climatiques ?
C'est une réalité, des faits.
-Oui, tout à fait.
-1 centimètre, 10 kilos par an.
-L'industrie automobile
a été dirigée
par l'industrie allemande.
On le sait, l'industrie allemande
a créé la voiture
telle qu'on la voit maintenant.
Tout le monde,
pour vendre ses voitures,
a été obligé de copier
les voitures allemandes.
Même les Chinois.
-La marche constructeur
est indexée au poids.
Un fabricant de voiture a intérêt
à vendre une grosse voiture
plutôt qu'une petite.
-Si vous avez
une voiture thermique
très lourde,
vous allez avoir des malus.
On le sait bien
en France.
On a intérêt, au contraire,
à diminuer le poids.
Vous avez des efforts
qui sont faits
sur tous les véhicules,
qu'ils soient français ou étrangers,
de changement complet
de conception.
On a un châssis
qui est plus boulonné
mais coulé d'une fois
pour économiser sur ce coût-là.
On bloque sur les batteries,
c'est sûr.
-Gros problème. Un tarif
de stationnement différencié
selon le poids du véhicule,
comme Lyon et Paris vont le faire,
c'est un bon début ?
-Oui, ça donne un signal :
pollueur, payeur.
Le principe, c'est ça :
on est dans des villes
où on a un espace lumité,
donc il est tout à fait normal
que le paiement du stationnement
se fasse au regard
de l'espace qu'on utilise.
-Ca pourrait freiner
la SUVisation galopante ?
-C'est un des signaux,
mais ça ne peut pas fonctionner
tout seul non plus.
De toute façon, quand on est
en ville, le vrai enjeu,
c'est de réduire
la place de la voiture
et de donner une vraie place
aux alternatives.
Lyon n'est pas du tout
en retard par rapport à ça.
On a besoin d'avoir
une dynamique générale
beaucoup plus importante
pour se déplacer autrement.
La voiture va garder une place.
C'est là où
je suis assez d'accord
avec ce qui est dit
dans le reportage.
On ne va pas se débarrasser
de la voiture.
Peut-être que des SUV,
on va en garder.
La problématique,
c'est qu'il n'y a plus que des SUV.
-Diriez-vous
que les constructeurs ont une part
de responsabilité en privilégiant
des voitures plus lourdes,
plus polluantes,
inadaptées à la vie urbaine
et plus chères, de 8 à 30 %
à moteur équivalent, à l'heure
des injonctions à la sobriété ?
-Bien sûr,
qu'ils ont une responsabilité.
Des choix ont été faits,
de privilégier
la rentabilité des modèles
au détriment
de la transition écologique,
de la réduction des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
et de la réduction des émissions
de polluants atmosphériques.
Ils ont une responsabilité.
Quand on regarde la façon
dont est menée
la conversion
vers l'électrique,
les SUV sont
majoritairement électriques,
car les constructeurs européens
ont choisi de rentrer
dans l'électrique
par des gammes élevées.
C'est aussi pour ça que le manque
de petits modèles accessibles,
peu émetteurs
et plus sobres,
est criant.
Il y en a pas assez.
C'est insuffisant.
-Ca permet d'accéder
aux subventions.
Même un SUV lourd
qui est électrifié,
jusqu'en 2025, je crois,
bénéficie
des aides à l'achat,
donc ça permet, artificiellement,
de baisser le prix.
-Là où je rejoins M. Roudier,
c'est que je pense,
en effet...
Les signaux qu'on a
sont ceux-là.
Il y a vraiment eu
une augmentation du poids,
avec des stratégies
très gros véhicule,
et on est un peu
sur un plateau.
A voir. Il va falloir
que ça se confirme.
Les alertes lancées
depuis des années
sur les véhicules trop lourds,
trop gros,
trop consommateurs de matière
et d'énergie,
se heurtent de plein fouet
à la nécessité dans les années
à venir d'économiser l'énergie,
de pas avoir des véhicules
qui consomment trop.
Les constructeurs vont chercher
plus d'aérodynamisme. On est
sur un plateau
dans la tendance SUV.
-Il faudrait des malus poids ?
-Absolument.
Je trouve
que la convention citoyenne,
qui a commencé à mettre
sur le devant
de la scène des belles propositions,
malheureusement...
-Ca a été détricoté.
-C'est pire que ça.
C'est que la puissance publique
ne veut pas réglementer.
On le fait
au niveau européen.
On est quand même
dans un objectif
de plus de normes
non pas
pour embêter les gens,
mais parce que, vous l'avez dit,
et c'est le cadre
de l'émission,
il y a une urgence climatique.
C'est les SUV
qui font repartir à la hausse
notamment nos émissions
de gaz à effet de serre.
Les SUV, aujourd'hui,
c'est un 6e pays émetteur
de gaz à effet de serre.
C'est un milliard de tonnes
de CO2. C'est énorme.
Je voudrais revenir sur une chose.
Moi, je pense
qu'on ne dit pas assez
la dangerosité.
Quand vous avez
des véhicules
qui sont sur nos routes,
qui pèsent plus de 1,8...
1,3 t ou plus,
c'est très dangereux.
La collision
avec ce type de véhicules,
c'est deux fois plus mortel
et là,
on va avoir un problème.
Aujourd'hui,
nous sommes
dans une trajectoire qui n'est pas
la bonne dans les transports,
raison pour laquelle
il va falloir légiférer.
C'est pas seulement,
et je suis d'accord,
avec la volonté qu'il faut
une taxe sur les stationnements,
etc.,
ça, c'est bien.
Mais comment
on crée les alternatives ?
C'est là où ça devient important
dans les villes,
les transports en commun,
plus de vélos et les autres choses.
-Le nouveau crédo
de l'industrie automobile semble
être "produire moins,
vendre plus cher".
La pollution des voitures
est indexée à la taille.
Elle est importante,
les émissions le sont.
Le problème ne vient pas
des moteurs, paraît-il,
mais des freins
et de l'abrasion. Exact ?
-Pas seulement du moteur,
effectivement,
si on parle
de pollution aux particules.
C'est un secteur qui est passé
dans l'angle mort
de la réglementation
pendant longtemps.
C'est-à-dire que les freins,
quand ça frotte,
ça crée des particules.
Et les pneus,
en contact avec le bitume,
ça met des particules en suspension.
On sait que c'est toxique.
Ce type de pollution
est responsable de plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de morts
en France,
pas uniquement les voitures.
Ca joue un rôle important.
Là, on se rend compte
de l'ampleur du phénomène.
Indépendamment
de la combustion et du moteur,
les particules fines issues
de ces deux types de frottement
représentent plus de 50 %
de la pollution locale.
Par ailleurs, je lisais
que sur les millions de tonnes
de microplastiques rejetés
dans les océans
chaque année,
plus de 25 % viendraient
des pneus.
On a vraiment
une pollution majeure,
pas directement liée
à la question climatique,
mais environnementale.
-L'UE a refusé de durcir
les normes de pollution
sur les gaz d'échappement
des voitures particulières
afin de préserver la compétitivité
de l'industrie automobile
et ses 14 millions d'emplois
en Europe.
Elle fait bien,
Karima Delli,
à l'heure où la pollution de l'air
tue de plus en plus ?
Selon les estimations,
entre 40 000
et 100 000 décès par an
en France.
-Elle ne fait pas bien.
Je suis en colère.
C'est un véritable scandale.
Aujourd'hui, on a une norme Euro 7
qui ressemble à la norme Euro 6.
En fait, on n'a pas bougé le truc.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que les constructeurs
automobiles disent :
"Si on met les véhicules thermiques
sur la norme Euro 7,
"ça va nous coûter 150, 200 euros."
Mais...
Ca ne coûte pas énormément.
Refaire le vernis de votre voiture,
c'est 550 euros.
Donc, vous voyez, là,
c'est une véritable question
de santé publique,
et moi, je pensais
que le fait
qu'on va sortir de la vente
des véhicules thermiques
en 2035,
si j'achète
un véhicule thermique en 2034,
il va rouler encore 15 ans,
20 ans, donc c'est là
qu'il faut mettre en place
la norme Euro 7 et v'là-t'y pas
que les constructeurs automobiles,
comme on dit chez moi,
ils ont fait un lobby
d'enfer sur toujours la même chose,
c'est-à-dire :
1,
le manque de compétitivité.
2 : menace à l'emploi,
alors que non,
il n'y a pas de menace
à l'emploi.
3 : la volonté de dire :
"On est leaders sur le marché.
"On va pas revenir en arrière.
"Notre trajectoire,
c'est de faire plus,
"notamment d'électrique."
Tout le monde ne roulera pas
à l'électrique.
-Là, en l'occurrence,
le lobby d'enfer, ça vous concerne.
Propos entremêlés
...
-Nous, c'est une réaction
tout à fait simple,
industrielle, commerciale :
on arrête les voitures thermiques
pas en 2035, mais en 2030.
Chez Stellantis,
c'est fini en 2030.
On ne va pas
dépenser de l'argent
pour la fin de portée
du thermique.
-Quid des véhicules
qui vont être achetés en 2029 ?
Ils vont rouler
jusque quand ?
-Vous avez dû le voir
dans les publicités :
on essaie de vendre
des voitures électriques.
Les publicités,
c'est pour les voitures électriques.
De toute façon,
dans les nouveaux modèles,
avant, on sortait
un modèle thermique
et une version électrique.
Maintenant, on dit
qu'il y a de l'électrique
et qu'il peut y avoir
des thermiques.
-Vous prenez en otage
la santé des gens.
-Elle ne dépend pas
des dernières voitures vendues.
Elle dépend du parc automobile.
-Justement !
-Vous, les politiques...
Le parc ancien automobile.
-Justement, la norme Euro 7...
-François Roudier.
-...sera là. M. Roudier,
vous êtes de mauvaise foi.
-François Roudier,
à Paris, on commence
à dépolluer l'air
dans les cours d'école,
avec des purificateurs d'air
géants.
C'est le cas
de l'école Victoire,
un établissement
du 9e arrondissement.
Que l'on en soit réduits à capter
les particules fines pour ramener
la pollution de l'air au-dessous
des seuils fixés par l'OMS,
vous trouvez ça normal ?
-Vous avez vu
ce qui roule à Paris ?
Que ce soit en voitures
particulières ou pire,
en camionnettes...
Non, mais c'est délirant !
On est quasiment
dans les années 70, maintenant.
Le problème,
c'est le parc automobile.
On a besoin des politiques
pour sortir ces véhicules...
Il y a 31 millions de voitures
avec les...
les VUL, les véhicules utilitaires
légers qui circulent.
Je ne vous parle pas des camions
de 3,5 t qui viennent de Pologne
ou de Lituanie...
-Comment vous allez en faire
des électriques ?
Vous appuyez sur un bouton
et on va avoir 31 millions...
-On peut déjà
rajeunir le parc.
-Quid, à présent,
de la voiture électrique
dont on nous vante
les mérites ?
Pour la rendre accessible à tous,
le gouvernement a rehaussé
le bonus écologique
pour les ménages les plus modestes,
de 6000 à 7000 euros selon
les critères de poids et de prix.
La liste des modèles subventionnés
sera connue en décembre.
Ces autos sont pourtant loin
d'être la panacée.
Raphaël,
c'est l'heure du Climatoscope.
-La voiture électrique
n'est pas la panacée,
effectivement.
Néanmoins, pas de doute
sur le fait qu'un véhicule
électrique a un impact carbone
moindre qu'un thermique.
On estime,
si on prend en compte
tout le cycle de vie,
qu'une voiture électrique a
un impact 2 à 3 fois inférieur
à celui d'une voiture thermique,
en moyenne. Au regard du climat,
la voiture électrique est mieux
qu'une voiture thermique.
C'est acquis.
On peut discuter de l'intérêt
de la voiture électrique.
-Pourquoi autant de critiques
et de sceptiques ?
-Ce qui est vrai, c'est que le bilan
carbone de la voiture électrique
à la fabrication
est moins favorable.
Il faut fabriquer
la carcasse,
le moteur et fabriquer la batterie,
très coûteuse en énergie,
et qui nécessite
d'aller chercher
du lithium, notamment,
dont l'extraction
est plutôt coûteuse.
Donc, au départ,
c'est plutôt un désavantage
environnemental,
mais comme on ne brûle pas d'essence
à son utilisation,
on rattrape, en fait,
ce bilan carbone
et on estime qu'en France,
en moyenne,
au bout de 50 000 km,
le bilan carbone
devient favorable
pour le véhicule électrique.
-En France,
mais quid des centrales
au charbon ?
-En France,
on a l'électricité
décarbonée.
En Pologne, c'est moins le cas.
La Chine, encore moins.
N'empêche
qu'au bout du compte,
en fin de vie du véhicule,
on a un bilan
CO2 favorable.
Ca prend plus de temps,
parce que le coût initial
est important,
mais à la fin, on y est.
Maintenant,
si on roule en véhicule
électrique,
est-ce qu'on est sur un versant
purement écologique ? Non.
Un autre paramètre est important.
C'est le poids du véhicule.
On en discutait tout à l'heure.
Le problème, c'est que le SUV,
même électrique, reste
une aberration, car la puissance
de la batterie qui est indexée
sur le poids du véhicule...
Gros véhicule,
grosse batterie, gros impact
et il est beaucoup plus difficile
de compenser les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
liées à sa production.
-Avec une électrique légère,
on n'est pas écolo ?
-Non, et on n'est pas encore arrivés
à destination,
quand on a une voiture légère
et électrique, parce que si on passe
de "Seul dans ma voiture thermique"
à "Seul dans ma voiture électrique",
on ne rentre pas
dans le cadre
des accords de Paris.
La neutralité carbone
impose une réduction
du nombre de véhicules
au niveau du parc,
ce qui veut dire du partage,
du covoiturage et augmenter
les transports en commun
pour permettre aux gens
de se passer de la voiture.
Aujourd'hui, c'est compliqué
en termes d'urbanisation,
mais si on veut que le transport
rentre dans les accords de Paris,
il va falloir agir
sur ces trois facteurs.
Il faut rentrer dans l'électrique,
alléger les véhicules,
faire des propositions de transport.
-Alors,
les batteries. Si les voitures
électriques restent ainsi,
des SUV à grosse batterie,
les matières premières
vont commencer à manquer pour
répondre à la demande croissante
d'ici 2035.
L'approvisionnement
en lithium
risque-t-il d'être
un autre problème,
Marie Chéron ?
-Il n'y a pas de problème
de réserve
de ressources disponibles.
La difficulté,
c'est le temps nécessaire
pour mettre en place,
ouvrir les mines, etc.,
et répondre à la demande.
C'est tout ce travail d'exploitation
et de mise sur le marché
des produits.
-Ca a un coût écologique,
l'extraction du lithium.
-Exactement.
-C'est loin d'être neutre.
-L'Europe
s'est défaite des activités minières
depuis des décennies.
-Enjeu géostratégique en plus.
-Il y a un vrai enjeu aujourd'hui
avec certains projets miniers.
-L'Union Européenne
souhaite relocaliser
la fabrication des batteries.
Beaucoup refusent
les gisements d'exploitation
de mines.
-D'un point de vue écologique,
le mal, il est aussi important
à l'autre bout de la planète
ou chez nous.
L'avoir chez nous,
c'est se mettre face à l'impact
de nos consommations et sans doute
de pousser vers la sobriété.
-Et peut-être
de réduire l'impact.
-Il y a aussi un gros enjeu
à avoir des activités minières
plus responsables,
et dans la responsabilité,
il y a aussi limiter
et maîtriser la consommation
qui va être extraite, et derrière,
l'autre enjeu,
c'est de mettre en place
dès aujourd'hui les activités
de recyclage qui vont permettre,
d'ici 10 ou 15 ans,
quand le stock de batteries sera...
de batteries en fin de vie
sera suffisant,
de pouvoir les recycler
et de les réutiliser.
Là-dessus, on a une directive,
un règlement,
au niveau européen
qui fixe des objectifs
de réutilisation
de métaux recyclés.
C'est quand même important.
On a ces 10-15 ans difficiles,
mais il y a un vrai débat
en France.
-Que dire
aux populations locales
qui voient d'un mauvais oeil
l'ouverture
d'une mine ? On l'a vu
à Echassières, dans l'Allier,
à Debrecen en Hongrie
ou à Loznica, en Serbie,
où les riverains se mobilisent
contre une usine de batterie
ou une exploitation de lithium.
Ils refusent
de sacrifier leur région
au nom
de la transition énergétique.
-Il faut analyser les projets,
voir s'ils sont implantés
au bon endroit.
C'est plus intéressant de le faire
sur des sites qui ont été
des endroits où il y avait
une exploitation minière
que dans des nouveaux sites,
comme c'est le cas en Serbie
ou au Portugal,
où on a des sites
qui sont aujourd'hui
des espaces agricoles,
avec des exploitations
et on vient proposer
un projet de mine.
Là, ça peut... Ca pose, de fait,
des problèmes.
Dans les sites repérés en France,
au départ,
il y a plusieurs sites
qui ont été explorés,
celui qui est retenu,
est un site anciennement...
déjà industrialisé,
donc oui, il faut faire
des choix raisonnés.
Je crois que ça,
ça va être essentiel.
Après,
il y a les questions liées
à la ressource en eau, etc.
La responsabilité...
-C'est pas neutre.
-Il faut être strict
sur la responsabilité
environnementale.
-Les voitures à hydrogène,
c'est un miroir aux alouettes ?
-Pour l'instant,
c'est une des solutions,
mais à grand gabarit,
sur des grands volumes de véhicules,
ça ne va pas être possible.
-Pour les flottes...
-Toyota y croit dur comme fer.
-En tout cas, pour l'instant,
c'est pas la panacée.
Je voudrais revenir
sur ce que dit
Marie Chéron.
Lorsqu'on a des visions
sur des mix énergétiques nouveaux,
l'industrie automobile
va devoir réfléchir
sur de la prospective de filière
et là, on a un problème,
parce qu'on ne doit pas juste
penser la batterie.
On doit penser l'ensemble
du véhicule et la filière,
c'est la seconde vie,
comment on recycle
les matériaux.
Et il y a un marché,
par contre,
sur lequel
on ne réfléchit pas assez,
c'est l'industrie du rétrofit.
Qu'est-ce que c'est ?
Vous avez un véhicule
thermique, on change le moteur
pour en faire un électrique.
C'est dingue, parce qu'on a
les meilleurs rétrofiteurs
en Europe.
-Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Renault le fait,
mais le problème,
c'est le coût
et la sécurité du véhicule,
qui a été fait il y a
quelques années, rétrofité,
avec une batterie
qui est plus lourde,
un freinage différent.
Les voitures électriques,
ça n'a pas le même comportement.
Un moteur thermique monte
en puissance.
Un moteur électrique,
c'est tout de suite.
-C'est dangereux ?
-Ca veut dire que...
Ca rajoute des contraintes
au rétrofit, ça rajoute du coût.
Mais c'est super
d'avoir des Méhari,
par exemple, électriques.
Ca marche.
Il y a un côté ludique
sur certaines choses
qui peut se faire.
Il peut y avoir aussi
des rétrofits de camions
et camionnettes.
C'est pas idiot.
-Pourquoi c'est plus pertinent
sur les camionnettes
que sur les voitures
individuelles ?
-C'est sur des usages
qui peuvent être plus courts.
Par exemple, la Poste
utilise des véhicules électriques
qui font du stop-and-go.
Ils ne font pas un grand trajet,
mais font du stop-and-go.
Vous n'avez pas la même contrainte
que sur un véhicule qui roule à 90.
-J'aimerais aller très vite
sur la question des biocarburants.
Il en est beaucoup question,
du superéthanol E85,
des carburants de synthèse,
comme l'e-fuel,
présentés comme l'essence du futur,
controversés.
Est-ce que l'Etat a raison
de leur multiplier
les cadeaux fiscaux ?
-Je ne suis pas d'accord
sur ça.
C'est un sparadrap
sur une jambe de bois.
Lorsqu'on a négocié notamment
la fin de la vente
des véhicules thermiques
au niveau européen,
les Allemands ont dit :
"On veut le carburant de synthèse."
Aujourd'hui, il n'y a pas
beaucoup de pays qui savent
faire des carburants
de synthèse.
En Europe,
on ne sait pas le faire.
On n'en a pas parlé,
mais je voudrais le redire,
c'est que s'il faut changer
des flottes,
il faut commencer
par les camions.
Parce que vous et moi,
les particuliers, on a
une alternative à la voiture.
On peut prendre un train, un bus.
Les marchandises, c'est compliqué.
-Vous oubliez la fracture
territoriale. D'ici 2025,
les villes de plus
de 150 000 âmes
devront mettre en place
des zones à faibles émissions.
43 métropoles sont
concernées.
Ces restrictions
de circulation sont
très fortement critiquées.
Elles risquent de creuser
un peu plus
la fracture territoriale.
-La fracture territoriale existe.
On a dit à tout le monde : "Ayez...
"un véhicule.
Non. Deux véhicules.
"Soyez notamment
dans le périurbain,
"rural,
ayez une belle maison",
sauf qu'à l'achat de deux véhicules,
pour les ménages,
aujourd'hui, un véhicule, en France,
c'est 5000 euros.
Ca fait 10 000 euros par an et...
Pas d'autre alternative.
D'où la question du déni,
et là, on peut le dire,
de la puissance publique
sur la question des gilets jaunes,
qui disaient : "C'est la goutte
d'eau qui a fait déborder le vase",
parce qu'ils n'avaient pas
d'alternative.
A votre question
sur les ZFE,
les ZFE vont devoir
être accompagnées
par des alternatives.
-ZFE, pardon ?
-LES ZONES
A FAIBLES EMISSIONS.
-C'est quand même dur
de dire : "Tel véhicule,
vous pouvez pas passer."
Vous avez un SUV électrique,
vous passez.
Quelqu'un qui a pas les moyens,
qui est en diesel,
il passe pas. Là, il y a
quelque chose d'injuste,
au niveau social. Je dis
qu'il faut mettre en place
les ZFE,
parce que c'est un...
un moyen incroyable
sur la pollution de l'air.
C'est pas moi qui le dis,
c'est l'ONU... l'OMS, qui dit que
c'est la maladie du 21e siècle.
Il faut le faire. Il va falloir
intensifier les alternatives.
-Difficile de parler de mobilité
sans parler de l'A69
et de ses 53 km d'autoroute
défendus par la présidente
d'Occitanie, Carole Delga,
pour relier Castres
à Toulouse,
qui prévoit d'ensevelir sous
le bitume 400 ha de terres agricoles
et de zones humides.
Un tronçon très décrié.
Est-ce que ce projet, à l'heure
des injonctions à la sobriété,
n'est-il pas
anachronique ?
-C'est anachronique
et c'est une aberration
économique, environnementale,
tout ce que vous voulez.
Une autoroute qui coûte 17 euros,
c'est une autoroute de riches.
On a la solution.
Il y a une voie
qu'on appelle le train.
Il faut la rénover, l'électrifier,
tout le monde sera content.
-François Roudier,
sur l'A69.
-Sur les autoroutes,
ce qu'on voit, c'est que ça devient,
effectivement,
la route du riche.
On a toutes les bornes électriques
sur les autoroutes,
ce qui fait qu'on reporte
tous le trafic des camions,
les 3,5 tonnes
qui roulent le week-end,
parce qu'ils sont pas interdits,
et qui détruisent les routes.
On a un état des routes, en France,
au national, ou pire,
lorsqu'on descend, qui est horrible,
qui, en plus, maintenant,
arrive à la charge
des communautés de communes,
qui ne peuvent pas les entretenir.
On déclasse des chemins,
des routes, tous les ans.
Vous parlez
de fracture territoriale.
La mobilité en ruralité,
c'est catastrophique.
Je le sais, j'en viens.
-Donc il faudrait
développer le rail ?
-Développer le rail,
ça veut dire déjà
faire venir le rail.
-Il y a beaucoup de lignes
qu'il faudrait réinvestir ?
-Le train, c'est gagnant-gagnant :
pour le climat,
pour le pouvoir d'achat,
et gagnant pour l'emploi,
car il faut embaucher.
-On nous a vendu un modèle
à l'américaine.
On ne peut plus faire sans bagnole.
-Absolument.
C'est pour ça que demain,
la voiture
ne sera plus dans la possession,
elle sera partagée.
Tout le monde roule un peu tout seul
dans sa voiture.
Dans le périurbain,
il faut revoir les cadences.
Le covoiturage,
c'est extraordinaire.
On n'a pas de routes
de covoiturage.
Il y en a partout en Europe,
sauf chez nous.
Il faut apprendre du Covid.
Que nous a appris le Covid ?
Qu'on peut moins se déplacer,
faire du télétravail.
Plein de gens dans les zones rurales
veulent un jour ou deux
de télétravail,
voire des lieux
qu'on appelle des tiers-lieux,
des lieux intermédiaires
où on peut travailler,
où il y a du lien social.
-Un jour par semaine,
c'est 170 000 barils en moins.
Trois jours,
c'est 500 000 barils.
-Il faut penser aux professions
qui n'ont pas le choix.
Je pense aux caissières,
aux infirmières,
etc., qui n'ont pas le choix.
C'est dans ces lieux-là
où il faut mettre
des bornes électriques.
-Il faut imaginer
des villes plus compactes,
plus propices à la marche.
-Voilà. Et au vélo.
-Alors, en attendant de façonner
nos villes autrement
et de laisser
la reine du bitume au garage,
certains se sont mis en marche
pour encourager nos enfants
à faire à pied ce qu'ils font
habituellement en voiture.
Tout le monde y gagne : la planète,
les marcheurs et le lien social.
Qui dit mieux ?
Le monde de demain commence
aujourd'hui,
comme le montre ce reportage.
-Marolles-en-Brie,
dans le Val-de-Marne,
au petit matin.
-Allez, les chaussettes.
-Maayan, 3 ans et demi,
se prépare à aller à l'école.
Lauriane,
sa maman, veille à ce que rien
ne manque dans le cartable.
-Tu mets ta tétine ?
Elle est où ?
Et la voiture ?
On prend le doudou,
et c'est tout, OK ?
Allez.
Tiens, le sac, allez.
Les chaussures, elles sont en bas.
Musique épique
...
On essaye de se préparer.
On est généralement en avance
parce qu'ils se lèvent tôt,
fort heureusement.
On les dépose pour 8 heures.
Tu fais le bisou à ta soeur ?
Le bisou ? Le bisou ? Le bisou ?
Ouais !
Bonne journée !
Allez, à tout à l'heure !
Bisous, mimine !
-En petite section de maternelle,
Maayan se sert d'un moyen
de locomotion original
pour aller à l'école.
-Est-ce qu'ils sont déjà arrivés ?
-Oui.
-Tu crois ? On va voir.
-Il utilise ses pieds.
Ca n'a l'air de rien,
mais un enfant qui marche
aujourd'hui, c'est un adulte
qui ne prendra pas
une voiture demain.
-Bonjour, Agnès !
-Bonjour, Maayan.
Tu vas bien ?
Hein ? Oui !
Bonjour !
-Ca va ?
-Agnès conduit le pédibus
depuis 2009.
-Regarde.
-Une alternative simple et efficace
à la voiture ou au car scolaire,
quand on sait qu'en moyenne,
les enfants habitent
à moins de 2 km de leur école,
et qu'un adulte sur deux
privilégie la voiture
pour les trajets de 1 km ou moins.
-Eh oui, tu vois, c'est la saison.
En automne, les marrons tombent.
On découvre les saisons.
C'est vraiment fabuleux.
Ils apprennent le nom des fleurs,
et on leur apprend aussi
à traverser les rues,
et puis les enfants sont éveillés,
ils sont bien, quoi.
Surtout, on donne un exemple
pour les autres parents,
pour que les enfants
marchent à pied.
-Aujourd'hui, 30 % des 26 millions
de trajets quotidiens
pour emmener les enfants à l'école
se font en voiture.
Ce sont autant de trajets
qui pourraient être évités
grâce à la marche.
C'est aussi un bon moyen de lutter
contre la sédentarité des enfants,
dont 17 % sont en surpoids,
en France.
-Bonjour, Sofia.
Bonjour, Julie.
-Ca va ?
-Ca va.
Voilà l'arrêt
de la ligne de pédibus.
Ici, c'est Batman.
C'est les enfants
qui ont donné le nom,
tout au début du pédibus.
-24 enfants sont inscrits
à ce service d'accompagnement
gratuit, assuré par des retraités
et par certains parents,
comme Flavie,
mère de deux petites passagères.
-Les filles sont ravies
de faire le pédibus tous les jours.
Il y a les copains.
Quand il pleut, c'est moins rigolo.
-Ca permet d'éviter
de prendre la voiture.
-Tout à fait.
Ca, c'est vrai que c'est pratique.
-Allez, Victoria, viens.
-Les deux dernières,
là-bas, c'est mes filles.
-Bonjour, Maëlle.
Bonjour, Edan. Ca va ?
-Le pédibus,
sympa pour les enfants...
-On attend que la voiture s'arrête.
Elle s'est arrêtée,
donc on peut passer.
Merci !
On lui dit : "Merci !"
-...mais ce n'est pas de tout repos
pour les adultes.
-Nawel ! Maayan ! Voilà.
On se met là,
et on regarde d'abord à gauche,
et après, à droite.
-En France, la voiture individuelle
représente 54 % des émissions
de gaz à effet de serre
du secteur des transports.
Favoriser la marche
pour les petits trajets
serait donc très bénéfique
pour notre planète.
-BONJOUR.
-Bonjour.
-Des petits pas
qui font de grandes avancées.
-C'est 25 minutes de marche,
mais même un petit
de petite section de maternelle
peut tout à fait faire ça.
La majorité des enfants
habite à peu près à 20 minutes,
donc tout le monde
pourrait venir à pied.
Musique légère
On va à l'école.
-Depuis 14 ans,
Agnès a accompagné
plus de 400 enfants.
En France,
on compte 800 lignes de pédibus,
et de nouvelles
sont créées chaque année.
Elles ouvrent toutes le chemin
vers un avenir plus durable.
-Les pédibus marchent du tonnerre.
Si on additionne
les 12 millions d'élèves
de la maternelle au lycée
au million d'enseignants,
c'est 26 millions d'allers-retours
chaque jour.
Ce n'est pas anodin
en termes d'emprunte carbone.
Ca fait du monde.
-Absolument,
ça fait beaucoup de monde.
Le problème que nous avons,
c'est de se dire :
"Il faut remarcher."
Ca veut dire que la voiture
nous a pris de l'imaginaire,
mais aussi dans notre comportement.
-La voiture
est le moyen privilégié
pour les trajets domicile-travail,
y compris pour les trajets
de moins de 5 km.
Ces distances pourraient facilement
être faites en mobilité douce, non ?
Qu'est-ce qui coince ?
-Je dirais
que c'est surtout ennuyeux
sur les trajets de 1 km.
Attention, parce que 5 km,
c'est souvent 5, plus 5, plus 5.
On va poser les enfants,
on va faire des courses,
on va au travail.
15 km, là,
on entre quand même dans des moments
où s'il n'y a pas de bus,
on prend la voiture.
C'est vrai que les enfants
qui sont emmenés en voiture
à l'école,
pour moi, qui suis un vieillard,
qui ai passé ma jeunesse à pied,
puis après, à vélo,
à faire 10 km par jour aller-retour,
et venir manger à la maison,
je ne comprends pas.
Je ne comprends pas
d'où est venue cette mode.
Est-ce qu'il y a eu une peur
sur la sécurité des enfants ?
Possible.
-Nos territoires ont été aménagés
pour et par la voiture.
-On voit dans le reportage
que le trottoir
n'est pas très large.
C'est quelque chose
qui est comme ça.
La voiture a pris de la place,
a grignoté.
Un parent ne laisse pas son enfant
aller à l'école seul
s'il y a un risque
de se faire renverser.
Il y a un enjeu d'aménagement
de circuits sécurisés, etc.
Plusieurs collectivités
travaillent dessus.
Quand on regarde en détail
le programme des villes,
c'est dur de recréer
de la signalétique,
des choses qui soient sûres,
pour faire ralentir les voitures,
pour que les enfants soient bien...
-Comment sortir du tout-bagnole,
sachant que le véhicule
reste la pierre angulaire
de nos déplacements ?
-Ca reste...
-Elle est obligatoire
pour beaucoup de gens.
-Surtout dans le périurbain
et dans le rural.
Dans les centres-villes,
aujourd'hui, on a les alternatives :
la marche, le vélo,
les transports en commun, etc.
Il faut un choc d'offres,
notamment d'alternatives,
dans le milieu rural
et dans le milieu urbain.
Par exemple, il n'y a pas assez
de fréquence de transports publics
dans le rural
et dans le périurbain.
Comment se fait-il ?
-Macron ambitionne de réduire,
d'ici à 2030, les émissions
de gaz à effet de serre de 55 %
par rapport à 1990,
et il s'est engagé à lancer
13 nouveaux projets
de RER métropolitains,
Karima Delli.
-Les RER métropolitains,
on est tous contents,
il y a plus de trains,
sauf qu'il faut dire la vérité :
ça va prendre du temps,
ça va prendre une dizaine d'années.
Qu'est-ce qu'il faut faire
maintenant ?
Il faut rénover les lignes de TER.
C'est la première chose.
Deuxième chose :
il faut plus de TER,
plus de fréquence.
Troisième objectif :
c'est le matériel roulant.
-C'est obsolète ?
-Si j'ai pas de train,
je peux pas mettre des trains
sur les lignes,
donc il faut rénover
la signalisation
et il faut lancer
l'industrie du train.
C'est extraordinaire.
-Le fameux ticket climat.
-Ca vient aussi au choc
de ce qu'on dit : l'accessibilité.
C'est la raison pour laquelle,
au niveau européen,
tout le monde met en place
des tickets climat.
Ce sont des abonnements illimités
pour prendre n'importe où,
par exemple en France,
pour 49 euros, tous les TER,
tous les transports en commun.
-Ca existe en Autriche,
en Allemagne, en Espagne.
-Et au Portugal.
Sauf que le gouvernement est malin,
il parle de pass rail,
pas de ticket climat,
car il voit juste les TER
et pas les transports en commun.
Quand je sors d'une gare,
je dois avoir un vélo,
un covoiturage,
un bus, etc.
C'est ça qui va faire en sorte
que demain,
la voiture prendra
de moins en moins de place.
Tu es d'accord ?
-Complètement, Karima.
-On va vous laisser.
-Il faut que
tous les différents modes
soient chaînés.
-Vous êtes d'accord ?
-Oui, aussi.
-Ah, bah voilà !
A l'unanimité !
-Vous arrivez avec un train,
la correspondance
est partie depuis 5 minutes.
C'est récurrent,
dans nos gares, en France.
Il y a vrai sujet
d'intermodalité.
Dans la gare, il y a pas forcément
de stationnement, le mode adapté
pour vous rendre à destination.
Il y a un vrai enjeu.
C'est insuffisant.
Il n'y a pas
de politique majeure dessus.
-En attendant,
on ne le répétera jamais assez,
la passé est un bon indicateur
de l'avenir.
Comme chaque mois,
Charlotte Epale est allée fouiller
dans les archives de l'INA,
et nous a exhumé ceci.
Hier encore, c'est notre coup d'oeil
dans le rétro.
-Cette fois, c'est sérieux.
A partir du 1er janvier prochain,
la lutte
contre les fumées des véhicules
va entrer dans une phase active.
Regardez ces camions,
les principaux fautifs.
Quand leur conducteur
change de vitesse,
un nuage noir se répand
dans l'atmosphère.
Cela provient souvent
d'un mauvais réglage du moteur.
L'arrêté du ministre
des Travaux publics
prescrit qu'aucun véhicule
ne pourra désormais émettre
de fumée
nettement teintée ou opaque.
Seules pourront être tolérées
les émissions fugitives
au moment des changements de régime
du moteur,
aussi bien les poids lourds
que les voitures.
Les services techniques
de la police vont contrôler.
A Paris, la préfecture de police
dispose d'appareils spéciaux,
qu'on branche sur le tube
d'échappement
des véhicules,
qui mesurent la quantité
et la nocivité des fumées.
Les échappements défectueux
doivent être présentés à nouveau.
Si l'amélioration
n'est pas suffisante,
une amande pourra,
à partir du 1er janvier,
être infligée au contrevenant.
Quelques dérogations
exceptionnelles
seront accordées.
Le combat contre la pollution
de l'air des villes
exigeait une action immédiate.
Elle est engagée.
-Elle est engagée,
Karima Delli ?
-Elle était déjà engagée
il y a quelques années.
Déjà à l'époque,
on calculait les particules d'air.
C'est toujours un des problèmes
moteurs de notre société.
-C'est le cas
de le dire.
Jeu de mot naturel.
Impossible de nous quitter
sans donner la parole
à notre écoactiviste préférée.
Camille Etienne
est de retour.
Elle a quelque chose à vous dire.
C'est l'heure de sa Carte verte.
C'est à vous.
-Le moins que l'on puisse dire,
c'est que la tendance
n'est pas au claquage de portière.
L'industrie de l'auto
n'a pas prévu de rouler au pas.
On n'a jamais vendu
autant de SUV qu'aujourd'hui.
Même s'il faut 10 tonnes de pétrole
pour construire une voiture,
que c'est un des plus gros facteurs
d'émissions de gaz à effet de serre
dans notre pays,
que les particules fines
donnent le cancer,
leur vente explose,
littéralement.
Même le président de la République,
dans un de ses discours officiels
nous glissait pourtant :
"Nous, les Français,
on adore la bagnole."
J'ai repensé
à tous ces souvenirs
construits dans mon technococon,
aux confessions sur le volant,
au copilote monomaniaque de Dalida,
aux engueulades avec mon frère,
pour savoir qui monterait devant,
aux sandwichs triangles
chers et pas bons,
aux jambes engourdies,
à la légère nausée,
et aux retours de nuit.
C'est vrai qu'on y est bien,
dans notre technococon.
On croit y être bien,
quand on oublie que les paysages
qui glissent à la fenêtre
disparaissent
à mesure des kilomètres.
On croit y être bien,
jusqu'à ce qu'on se prenne le mur
de la catastrophe climatique.
L'impact sans airbag, ni ceinture,
vers lequel l'industrie automobile
nous projette à vive allure.
La vraie question,
et peut-être la seule,
qui devrait nous obséder,
c'est de savoir si la voiture
roule encore pour nous,
ou si c'est nous qui roulons
pour que son industrie
continue à faire du profit.
Le philosophe Jacques Ellul alertait
sur le lien de domination
entre l'homme et l'outil.
Il y a ce point de bascule
au-delà duquel le rapport s'inverse.
On devient
à son service
plus que l'inverse.
En 1973, déjà,
Ivan Illich faisait le calcul.
Un Américain moyen consacre
1600 heures par an à sa voiture,
soit 4 heures par jour.
Il y a le temps en voiture, certes,
à celui-ci s'ajoute le temps
de travail pour la payer,
puis payer l'essence,
les péages, l'assurance,
les impôts et les réparations.
Pour tout ce temps donné,
l'Américain moyen parcourt
une distance de 10 000 km.
Il avance donc à 6 km/h.
C'est à peine plus
qu'une marche rapide.
Je rentre d'un week-end
de mobilisation
contre l'autoroute A69,
entre Castres et Toulouse.
Pour gagner 17 minutes,
des centaines d'arbres,
des hectares de terres cultivables
et des gens expropriés
de leur maison sur le tracé.
Entre garder des champs
pour se nourrir
et agrandir les routes
pour aller plus vite au supermarché,
ils ont choisi.
Plus de 1500 scientifiques
du GIEC et du CNRS nous alertaient.
Chaque mètre carré de terre
que l'on artificialise
participe à compromettre
les conditions de vie sur Terre.
D'ici à 2050,
il y aura plus de 25 millions
de kilomètres
de route supplémentaires,
soit 600 fois le tour de la Terre.
On roule à plus de 110 km/h
vers une sixième extinction
de masse.
A coups de pelleteuse,
nous sommes en train
de manger le monde
et de couler la vie sous du bitume.
Pour gagner quelques minutes
de trajet,
ils accélèrent notre chute.
On continuera
à ralentir leur monde,
contre leurs péages,
à leur faire payer l'enlaidissement
du monde qu'ils nous imposent.
Face à leurs couloirs de bitume,
on choisit des chemins de traverse.
Face à la honteuse direction
du monde
qu'ils nous disent inévitable,
on construit une autre route, venez.
-François Roudier,
vous écoutez avec attention.
-Je respecte toutes les religions.
-Belle religion, madame.
-Vous n'avez pas envie
de répondre quelque chose ?
-C'est un beau texte.
-Oui ?
-On partage pas mal de choses.
Détruire des paysages,
c'est une catastrophe.
Utilisons déjà
tout ce qui a été implanté
pour l'améliorer.
-Voilà.
-Aidez-nous
contre l'A69.
-Avant de se quitter,
voici des recommandations
de lecture pour aller plus loin.
Je ne vais pas vous faire plaisir,
François Roudier.
"Moins d'auto pour aller au boulot",
de Corentin Le Martelot,
dans la collection
"Je passe à l'acte",
aux éditions Actes Sud.
"Tout comprendre (ou presque)
sur le climat",
préfacé par Valérie Masson-Delmotte
aux CNRS Editions,
et "Chaleur humaine",
de Nabil Wakim,
aux éditions du Seuil.
Bonne lecture.
D'ici-là, soyez heureux.
On se retrouve le mois prochain
pour vous parler du béton.
Vaste sujet.
Merci à tous.
SOUS-TITRAGE : RED BEE MEDIA